and right there i was like this stealing
[__] ain't for me it's too easy to get
caught you know
but i would still steal like little
bicycles and [__] i had a neighbor of
pharaoh and he would
[__] trim up the numbers and put like
a banana bar on and [__] like that
you know and then i never got
i don't have a juvenile record i have
nothing nothing like i didn't have
police contact
where i was growing up there was a cop
and he would give you a card with his
name and his number on the back it said
extend all [__] courtesies do not
arrest unless he stabs your mother in
the [__] eye
so that means before they arrested you
they would have to call him and say you
know
he broke a window and then let him go
who gives a [__] you know
the only contact i ever had growing up
like the number one thing i was really
good at was dining and dashing
and it wasn't a felony at the time i
think it's a felony now they caught on
we were going to the wing chun fountain
it was the wing fung
chinese restaurant and we were going
there eating and run the [__] out and
they wouldn't chase you they laughed but
we did it so much
that then they would chase you we got
good at it we got so good they would
play like a zone defense on me when i go
in there
they would put like a chinese guy by the
door or another guy by the [__] thing
another guy by the noodles they had me
[Laughter]
they had me those [__]
dining and dashing is like eating and
having to run
afterward like they're gonna [__]
like one weekend i ran i didn't run out
of the wingfund i ran out of willyu
shanghai palace in cliffside park new
jersey
they had tremendous and those
[__] chased this nine or eight
miles
they chased me so much i got sick and i
got like a like a flute bug
and i lost [__] 20 pounds so the
chinese food
they put the kiss of death on me that's
why
and then there was another place called
the maikai on kennedy boulevard
and they had an all you could eat that
was [__] amazing and one night they
they knew it because their reputation
got out
we had like little wanted posters at all
the chinese restaurants
[Applause]
so we went into the into the maikai late
night and as we were running out they
locked the door on us and i'll never
forget that we banged the door and my
friend
looked and they go where's the dishes
[__] and that was it
one of the kids that was with us his
father was a cop
and i was talking about him last week
that their father was a big wall
czechoslovakian they were [__]
ginormous
they were hunters and [__] i never
forget like we're like oh my god he's
like oh my god my dad's on shift
and he used to have glasses and they had
scott's tape in the middle of them all
the times the father would punch him in
the face
and break his [__] glasses right that
[__]
one time he beat him in school but he
didn't beat him your father beat you
this way
that's a traditional way right no his
father would stand next to him like he
would be here stand right there
hey this is the teacher yes my son did
that bam
and the kid was four and then he'd pick
him up get up [__]
what bam and he just gave him backhand
backhands like eight of them in front of
everybody they didn't give a [__]
you didn't dial 9-1-1 then my dad hit
you he's a cop what are you going to do
[__]
so i never forget that the dad came and
he took us outside and said what the
he put whatever 40 hours up and we had
to pay him the next morning
and that's the closest i ever came as a
juvenile to getting [__] arrested
that was it